ما زالت الحرب تفرض سطوتها على خيرسون
رغم انسحاب الروسي منها يتواصل القصف
ويشتد البرد وتنعدم خدمات الماء والكهرباء
هكذا صارت المدينه في زمن الحرب متعبه
منهكه
من واقعها هذا انشات السلطات الاوكرانيه
نقاطا لتوزيع المياه على من بقي من
السكانفا لجون من الموت باعجوبه لكننا
فقدنا الماء والكهرباء وكل شيء
تنتظر حصتها من الماء
كبيره لكن احتياجاتهم اكبر ونحن نعمل بجد
لتلبيتها
في مكان اخر تتجلى صوره اخرى ليوميات
الحرب مثل هذه الخيام تنتشر بكثره في عموم
المدينه اطلقت عليها السلطات تسميه خيام
الحقيقه وزودتها بمولدات الكهرباء لتسهيل
حياتنا الناس
اتت لشحن مصباحها عله يضيء ما خلفته عتمه
الحرب
لا املك الكهرباء في منزلي اريد الحصول
على اي بصيص امل من اجل اولادي نامل ان
يكون هناك حل كريم
بات كفاحا يوميا في خير سول
لمده طويله عن امدادات الطاقه وفي ظل
عرقيل توفيرها للجميع ناشدت السلطات
السكان ضروره النزوح الطبيعيه الى مناطق
وسطي وغربي اوكرانيا الاقل تضررا
انسحب الرسوم من خيرسون اذا لكنهم تركوا
ورائهم اثار حب ثقيله حرب لا زال صداها
يسمع في الارجع الجزيره خير سو